in this video we'll talk about Lambert
Eton syndrome and this is a high yield
video for USMLE step 1. Lambert Eton
syndrome is a rare autoimmune disorder
characterized by muscle weakness and
fatigue
common symptoms include proximal muscle
weakness autonomic dysfunction and
decreased reflexes
in Lambert
Eton syndrome immune system mistakenly
attacks the voltage-gated calcium
channel in the presynaptic terminal here
you can see in the presynaptic terminal
there are vgccs or voltage-gated calcium
channels
they allow calcium to enter the
presynaptic terminal and that is crucial
for neurotransmitter release
and that aspect is abrogated in the
neuromuscular Junction this results in
lesser neurotransmitter that is
acetylcholine release from the
presynaptic terminal which ultimately
lead to a decrease in muscle contraction
eventually might lead to muscle
paralysis
so overall acetylcholine release in the
synaptic cleft is decreased in Lambert
Eton syndrome
it is often associated with patients
with small cell lung cancer and it's a
proximal muscle weakness which improves
with repeated muscle exercise
in this video we'll talk about the
pathology genetics diagnosis and
eventually the treatment options for
Lambert Eton syndrome let's talk about
the clinical presentation first
typically Lambert Eton syndrome is
presented by the proximal muscle
weakness and fatigue so the weakness is
generally confined to the lower
extremities and more visible in the
lower extremities so there are limb
related problem a normal individual can
cause this kind of movement and the
range of motion is pretty nice but if
you think about a Lambert Eton syndrome
patient this kind of range of motion is
not possible to make due to a proximal
muscle weakness
other symptoms include autonomic
dysfunction and hyporeflexia that means
the reflexes become weak
let's talk about the pathophysiology of
Lambert Eton syndrome in order to
understand we have to understand the
neuromuscular Junction because it's a
disease of neuromuscular Junction in the
neuromuscular Junction in the
presynaptic terminal there are calcium
channels and these are voltage-gated
calcium channels the voltage-graded
calcium channels allow calcium to come
in and acetylcholine to be released in
the synaptic cleft there are often uh B
cells or plasma cells which secrete
antibody against these voltage-gated
calcium channel which lead to less
calcium influx in the presynaptic
terminal if the calcium influx is less
less vesicles would be released and
there would be eventually less
neurotransmitter in the synaptic cleft
just let me remind you in myasthenia
gravis the things are different the
postsynaptic acetylcholine receptor was
affected in this case and the antibodies
are against postsynaptic acetylcholine
receptor so in Lambert eaten syndrome
the pre-synapses affected and in the
mycena gravis the postsynaptic so the
muscle is directly affected
let's talk about the diagnosis of Lumbar
Eton syndrome it can be diagnosed with
the help of electromyography in Lambert
Teton syndrome the patient's
electromyogram shows a characteristics
decremental response when repetitive
stimulus is provided and this is this
can be visualized with the help of
electromyography
other than electromyography there could
be detection of anti-vgcc Auto
antibodies in the patient's serum and
that can be done via Elisa based assays
now what is the biggest difference
between the Lambert Eton syndrome and
myasthenia gravis both are neuromuscular
Junction disease but in case of Lambert
Eton syndrome the attack is presynaptic
means the presynaptic voltage-gated
calcium channels are attracted whereas
in myasthenia gravis the postsynaptic
acetylcholine receptors are attracted
now the key differential is with with
kind of exercise the overall performance
would be better in case of Lumbar Eton
syndrome but in case of myasthenia
gravis there is no improvement and
things even may go worsen
so get more notes and flashcards in my
channel you can visit Instagram or
Facebook for more notes see you in next
video you can support us using super
tanks
be good